Prince Harry and Megan Markel get close  in the Caribbean  [Music]  the 32 year old Prince and the suit star  are currently in Jamaica for a friend's  wedding and were spotted having an  intimate chat with one another during  the reception while enjoying some  champagne Megan looked regal as ever in  a green and navy floor-length gown while  her man matched his ladylove in a navy  suit but rocked only his white  button-down for the party on the beach  harry was later seen taking a dip in the  ocean wearing blue trunks a grey hat and  shades accessorizing the look with his  royal six-pack ABS Prince Harry and  Megan sure seemed to be heating up and  spending plenty of time together but  these to be next to walk down the aisle  we sure hope so let us know your  thoughts over on Twitter at ET now  [Music]  you